look at the trial that's going on this
week the trial of kyle rittenhouse
you remember kyle rittenhouse during the
blm riots as the left was torching the
country and killing people and setting
things on fire and we were told it was
all mostly peaceful there was a young
man kyle rittenhouse who
was armed he was protecting himself but
he was he was going just trying to clean
up the neighborhood trying to help the
shop he was working at and some
left-wing
terrorists were coming after him and
kyle rittenhouse shot them quite
apparently in self-defense so now
because kyle rittenhouse is a
right-winger and the
people who were chasing him and
threatening him were left-wingers
the left is trying to portray him as a
murderer they're trying to throw him
away for a long time
so the trial's underway
and it's really not going well for the
prosecution because regardless of what
the media told us regardless of the
narrative that they were spinning
even the witnesses that the prosecution
is calling
are
ultimately defending rittenhouse
i mean you have no idea
what mr rosenbaum was ever thinking at
any point in his life you have never
been inside his head you never met him
before you don't i've never even i've
never exchanged words with him if that's
what your question is
so your interpretation of what he was
trying to do or what he was intending to
do or anything along those lines is
complete guesswork isn't it um
well he said you and then he reached for
the weapon
rosenbaum is one of these guys that
written house killed and uh in
apparently in self-defense so you have
no idea you don't know
maybe he
maybe he was reaching for his weapon to
give it to kyle rittenhouse as an early
birthday present maybe when he said fu
maybe that was just his love language
maybe that was just his how do you have
no idea you can't get in the mind of
another
person uh yeah well he screamed fu and
reached for his weapon so you know
that's i'm not i'm no sherlock holmes
here
but something tells me he wasn't trying
to wish me a happy birthday i love
mizzen and maine
i love missing in maine primarily
because it makes me look really really
cool they're shirts they're they're
oxford shirts they're polo shirts make
me look really really cool and sleek and
hip and and cool
but there's another layer here which is
they combine the comfort and flexibility
of your favorite athletic wear with the
fit and style of a custom dress shirt
lightweight breathable moisture wicking
i am of italian extraction we perspire a
little bit okay this is not great with
some other dress shirts and some other
polos with mizzen and main
not a problem at all i don't need to
worry about that kind of thing the dress
shirts are also machine washable so you
can skip the trips to the dry cleaner
think of all the time think of all the
money you'll say they've got 30 000
five-star reviews you know they make a
great product i i love them i love them
whether you're updating your wardrobe to
head back to the office or just looking
for a new fall flannel
we've got really good news right now if
you go to
mizzenandmaine.com use promo code
knowles you'll get 35 off any regular
price order of 125 bucks or more 35 off
when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com use promo
code knowles another witness the
prosecution grilling this witness the
facts really not looking good for
the left
i stepped in and told everybody chill
out calm down stop doing that
i turned and had an exchange with one of
the protesters
and
i kind of explained to that protester
hey
you know i get it get what you're trying
to do but like not this
and when i turned around
rosenbaum was right there in front of my
face
yelling and screaming
and
i would say dude back up just chill
i don't know what your problem is and he
goes you know what if i catch any of you
guys alone tonight i'm gonna kill you
and he said that to you correct did he
say that to the defendant as well the
defendant was there
so yes
oh my gosh
uh look i think
from the facts that we know it's been
clear from the earliest stages of this
the kyle rittenhouse was acting in
self-defense he certainly should not be
convicted of any crime and this this is
basically a witch hunt
uh
but
if the state is going to prosecute this
i think they need a better lawyer
in this guy or maybe it's just the case
that all the facts
are on the side of the right here and
they're on the side of kyle rittenhouse
and
they're against the media and the
leftists and the government but i repeat
myself
the guy
said to their faces if i catch you alone
tonight i'm going to kill you
is there any clearer justification for
acting in self-defense probably not
the narrative
the left-wing narrative can last for a
very long time
i don't mean to downplay it
but eventually eventually
the truth is going to peak out how did
you like that clip did you like it i
hope you liked it if you did maybe you
leave me a comment maybe you ring that
bell maybe you get those notifications
more importantly though
head on over to apple podcasts or
spotify or google play or stitcher
or your record player in your living
room or wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review i
greatly appreciate it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you